hi everyone uh thank you all for tuning
in to our panel discussion on the
science behind the alexa ai
my name is yang leo i'm a principal
applied a scientist
working at alexa ai this video is
pre-recorded so we cannot take your
questions
live but there are many opportunities
for you to connect with our scientists
during and after the in the speech
conference
so we highly encourage you to visit our
virtual booth
to meet with us and learn more about
alexa ai
i'm very excited to connect with you
throughout this week
i am very pleased to welcome my
colleagues
scientist karthik goplakrishnan will
hamza and
fabian trevenba they are
scientists working primarily on alexa ai
but along with other scientists that
alexa ai
they are driving the customer of science
the science
so first let's take a few minutes to
introduce ourselves
as i just mentioned my name is yang i'm
a principal appliance scientist at
alexa ai i'm working
on both open domain as well as task
orientated dialogue
so this involves language understanding
response generation
and then some other aspects of dialogue
some of you may have heard alexa price
social wealth grand challenge
this is a challenge organized by alexa
ai
it's a university competition that
encourages
university student teams in developing
social bots so we can push the
boundaries of
conversational ai for this new year the
fourth annual challenge has just
kicked off with a call for application
proposals
uh we are very forward looking forward
to seeing the new results coming out
from this new round
and by what way i'm also on the
organizing committee for this year's
into speech conference
so karthik sure hi
hi everyone my name is karthik i'm an
applied scientist at lxia
i work on generative and retrieval based
models for knowledge grounded dialogue
and i focus primarily on open domain
dialogue
and i work on this along with yang and a
few others on our team
i joined amazon after school because i
wanted to
apply the foundations that i built in
school and machine learning towards like
problems that
directly impact customers
thanks karthik uh well
thanks hank uh yeah my name is uh i am a
principal applied scientist in the alexa
ai
organization i lead the
team of scientists we work on
deep learning algorithms and methods for
natural understanding my team focuses on
problems like understanding the input of
the
you know customers to alexa that
includes the domain classification and
classification slot failing semantic
parsing and and various
other natural understanding methods i'm
really excited to be part of
alexa particularly alexa because
it's actually an opportunity for me and
scientists like me
to apply all the machine learning uh you
know
uh knowledge and ideas uh
to something that goes directly to
serving customers you know the values
that we
that amazon holds dear such as you know
customer obsession bias for action
think big and other principles make our
life as a scientist more exciting than
just
coming up with an idea but just taking
those ideas and
putting them in front of customers to uh
to have an impact
uh using machine learning so that's a a
bit of excitement about
my life at amazon and particularly alexa
i can pass it to fabian
hi my name is fabian i'm applied science
manager located in athens germany
and in africa we actually have multiple
teams working on alexa's speech
recognition and natural language
understanding components
and my team specifically actually we
tried to to streamline feature and
language expansion for alexander u so we
want to teach alexa
new languages new capabilities and we
want to make that process as easy and as
painless as possible for our scientists
and developers and to do so we focus on
areas like deep learning data
augmentation
cross-lingual learning and all the
aspects that help us to reduce human
effort and
data needs to to expand alexa to new
marketplaces and
to delight more customers with these
experiences
and what brought me to amazon is
actually that i joined like
more than six years ago uh in the very
early days of alexa development um when
we just started to build the product
and before i did a phd on speech
recognition using neural networks and my
motivation
was mostly to apply this research to
actual problems to actual products and
to
develop the large-scale solutions which
we were
thinking of such solutions could help
with and to bring them to production and
to really delight customers
by building products that are really
used by millions of people
this day thank you all
for the introduction so you see whether
we are located in different places
california new york and ahu germany
and i know all of us here have written
or authored some of the publications
that have been
accepted or will be presented at a
conference soon
i want to touch on some of the papers or
the research coming out of these papers
i will maybe you can start by giving us
some
summary of the research that your team
is going to present at intel speech
sure uh sure yang thanks uh yeah so one
of the
papers i would recommend that that
people who are attending enter speech to
look at is our paper
uh regarding the style it's actually
entitled style attuned pre-training and
parameter efficient fine-tuning
for spoken language understanding and as
you know and as i said in the
introduction that we
develop machine learning algorithms and
methods
to handle uh customer input to
understand customer input you know and
our
customers talk to alexa uh regarding
many subjects you know music weather
shopping
uh home automation so many of these
applications we also allow third party
developers to develop their own domains
which we call alexa skills
and as known to the community deep
learning models to understand
all these domains are going to be heavy
uh models and
you know to have mod deep learning
models for all these domains may be
difficult to train and difficult to
serve in production so the paper shows a
very interesting
way of you know pre-training
those models or big portions of these
models
and then use these uh pre-trained models
into
domain specific or task-specific model
the problem is if we use
a deep model a full deep learning model
for task specific
models we will have a huge humongous uh
size of model and it may be difficult to
train and difficult to
uh to serve so the paper shows that we
can actually uh
pre-train a big portion of the model and
share it between all the domains and
all the tasks and only add a little bit
of test specific or domain specific
set of parameters uh to actually serve
all these domains and all these skills
the paper shows that by
adding four percent of the parameters we
can add a new domain or a new task or a
new skill
without affecting the performance we
also have shown in the paper a few
techniques of how we do that and
how we train you know task specific
models without losing performance
uh from the final model so we're excited
to present this effort and
we're happy that it it is coming to
enter speech
thanks a whale what this is a good
example of customer of assess the
research
paper is trying to address a real world
problem
karthik i know you are the primary
author for
that looked at whether the neural
network
vista model is for open domain dialogue
systems
and whether this kind of approach is
requested to speech recognition output
um can you tell us more about it yeah
sure
thanks uh so basically a very large
pre-trained transformer based language
models have become ubiquitous in uh
nlp uh and this has led to like a
regular focus and interest in
in in the community on end-to-end neural
open domain chatbots that is like bots
that can directly generate or retrieve
responses
given a dialogue history and uh like
state-of-the-art open domain chatbots
have been built using such large
language models but uh the the
underlying assumption with these models
is that the like the user input is like
in the form of written text uh
but as an alexa like you know speech is
like a popular modality
uh due to the ubiquity of assistance
like alexa so we asked ourselves the
question
can like large text-based end-to-end
open domain chat parts like seamlessly
integrate with
asr models to support this modality
and esr models are essentially imperfect
allies in contrast to life perfect
adversaries and there's been a lot of
work on adversarial attacks and
perturbations on language models
so what we did was we adopted like an
empirical first principles approach and
we performed allied attacks
to a state-of-the-art uh gpt-based open
domain dialog system
in the form of synthetic and actual asr
errors and we demonstrated that such
errors can
hurt the performance of these systems
significantly and we also demonstrated
like marginal gains from like a simple
mitigation strategy of introducing
uh such errors during training and
there's like a considerable uh
room for improvement like the goal of
the paper was to primarily promote uh
speech robustness as an evaluation
criterion in open domain dialogue
and foster research towards making
end-to-end neural open domain dialogue
models more speech robust and in this
spirit what we also did was
we also open source the data set that we
used for our study
which we call topical chat asr which is
just an asr augmentation of the largest
open domain
uh text based dialogue data set topical
chat which was also released at indus
beach
last year actually
thanks karthik um i'm very glad i'm also
a co-author on that publication
we all know in guaranteed dialogue
systems there's a lot of research
looking at how speech affects the spoken
language and the spending performance
and we hope our publication will let the
community
pay more attention to open domain
dialogue systems
i also want to briefly mention two other
speech papers i have
co-authored both of those are related to
entity recognition
and anti-linking one paper is about
anti-linking
also called entity resolution when the
user mentions an
entity for example san francisco it may
mean
multiple things it can be the city of
san francisco it can be
the airport and maybe a sport team so we
need to resolve that entity to
a real world object and in this paper
we use rich information to decide
what the entity refers to and the
information includes
the context of where entity has appeared
on the description of the entity itself
and the relationship of
entity with others in a knowledge graph
and we showed good results
another paper is about the correcting
esr errors for
entity recognition and energy retrieval
for speech recognition system some of
the entities are auto vocabulary words
and they often cause
recognition errors in this paper we use
a transformer based model
that incorporates phoneme information
trying to correct esr errors for
entities and we show the improvement for
both
recognition performance for entity words
as well as
downstream entity retrieval tasks
and okay i'm going to pass through
whether fabian eu team has a paper on
spoken language
understanding looking at the low
frequency classes
can you tell us more about that research
yeah sure so the problem we tackle here
is actually a real world product use
case so the situation is that
the user's usage patterns or voices
systems like alexa they're very
imbalanced so it is very often that the
distribution of intents and slots
is very skewed and in practice that
means that we observe many
high frequency used command and control
requests like i don't know music
requests or
turning on and off devices for your home
automation but other features
are less frequently used for example
starting this
smart home discovery mode on the device
which is rarely used but still very
important
so these features with little usage
they're they're not always less relevant
but just
less frequently used so let's take a
very practical practical example
so if you if you lost your phone at home
um you might for example call it we
alexa just to try
to find it back in your apartment and
while this is a very
rare use case that you don't ask this
very often for your own phone
if you do it should always work right
because you want to ensure the greatest
customer experience
so there are many more of these examples
and they also even inside specific
features they're very different ways how
people
request functionality and given the
large diversity of our customer base
there's a lot of way how this is done
and a lot of flexibility in the user
requests
so this kind of imbalancing of the data
has not been really studied at scale for
natural language understanding in
literature
and this made it made us actually
curious to to solve the problem and to
tackle it
from a more research angle and in the
paper we brought in the speech
we actually address it by trying to get
the tail
of the less frequent utterances improved
in quality
but without impacting the quality of the
head of the intents and slots so we try
to
really move up the tail by not impacting
the greater customer experience on the
things that are
frequently used and always work in a
high quality so in the publication we
propose to use different
data balancing solutions which are
sometimes very classical approaches
but we also leverage an auxiliary task
training which makes use of a new
class balanced batch generator and this
incorporates additional synthetic
training data into the workflow
so by teaching the system to actually
focus on the less frequent examples
we demonstrate that there are great uh
potential for
movements on the tail but without any
degradation on the head intense so the
frequently used functionality
and in addition we also demonstrate and
studied a little bit how
synthetic data in the life cycle of
feature development can be used and what
is the best way to
bootstrap new features while later
balancing
more realistic data with synthetically
bootstrapped data and when is the time
to actually
fade out all data when to use new data
and when this
auxiliary task training can help us to
focus on the white data at the right
time in model bidding
so this is what we address in this
publication and it's um
as i said in the intro a very
customer-facing solution we drive here
because it helps
our customers to just get a better
experience and by not having any
degradation on known experiences and
known features they are used to
thanks fabia that's another good example
of research trying to help with
real user experience thank you all for
the summary of what the publications you
have already
you have co-authored and you may have
noticed
this panel of scientists that is
primarily focused on
areas of natural language understanding
and opie or dialogue
and we all know alexa science also has
many many scientists
working on speech processing related
fields
and actually in this conference there
are many other papers by
alexa scientists about the speech
recognition
esr tts weak word detection
speaker diarization rich transcription
slu
etc uh will maybe you can
share with us your thoughts on how a no
union alexa ai
works in concert with other areas in
speech
such as acoustic models or esr
yeah thanks hank someone like me who
worked with asr before spent almost half
of my research life doing tts
and now now to natural language i tend
to
believe that i uh you know know more of
these things but the
as you said the areas of research and
and science progress
across all these disciplines and areas
of research is becoming
a lot and you can tell from the
inter-speech
publications how much effort is done in
this area particularly also from alexa
scientists
and i invite all of you to you know
attend
uh some of the panels also that are
going to be attended by
our science colleagues from the asr and
the wake ward and the
tts team uh you know to get
an idea also of what is happening on
these fronts and then this this session
and the other session will also be
available uh
on amazon science website i would like
to
bring the attention to something that
you know that is becoming popular also
in the research community
which is you know demolishing the the
boundaries between those
areas of research and now we are
beginning
you know the community is beginning to
look into solutions that are
you know end-to-end solutions so one of
the areas that are
becoming popular is the area of uh doing
nlu
on the speech signal directly so you
take the speech as input you don't do
asr followed by nlu
you just do you know nlu right away from
from speech and and we regret to miss
uh enter speech for one of the papers we
have been working on but we
promised to publish soon but you can
find maybe several of these papers in
enter speech and in other conferences
it's an area of
attention nowadays another area of
attention is to instead of acting on
what the asr produces
the nlu systems for example would act on
the
you know world lattices or n best uh
output of the asr
systems which gives more robustness to
asr errors and
it helps make the nlu and subsequent
components
uh much better a lot of exciting areas
on these
you know combined and end-to-end systems
uh that i
invite all of you to look into and and
do research on
thanks will and indeed there's a lot of
work on and to end
so starting from the speech signal all
the way to
the final understanding results and even
um just in terms of the approaches used
for
asr tts and the i know so
there's a lot of similarity pre-trained
language models transformers the
sequence of sequence approaches are used
in all of these problems so yeah the
blurry
what they are the boundary is getting
weather um blurry
um so thank you to all of you for
sharing these insights and then whether
giving us
some summary about the research you have
been involved
to close out i would like to hear from
each of you on where you see the future
headed
and for myself i have been in this field
for more than two decades and i've seen
a lot of progress
especially in the past few years in
speech and nlp
mostly because of deep learning
approaches and
more computing resources and large
amount of data available
uh so what are you most excited about uh
where do you think where do you
think about there will be challenges or
what's next for
conversational ai
um card taker maybe you can start sure
yeah so i think i'm really excited about
uh scalable training of larger language
models for
desirable downstream attributes so like
i had mentioned earlier
language modeling as a field and more
specifically open domain dialogue as a
subfield
has seen a sport of larger language
models trained on very large amounts of
data
and some generally desirable attributes
from such language models include like
you know factually accurate and bias
free sequence generation
uh more specifically downstream and open
domain dialogue like you know some other
desirable attributes
would be like accurate grounding of
knowledge uh empathy
common sense uh system persona user
personalization etc and these are all
very hard challenges and the open domain
dialog community as a whole is
is doing quite interesting work along
these lines uh one challenge i think i'm
especially looking forward to is like
effectively
incorporating the notion of temporality
in large language models
via continual learning mechanisms given
that world knowledge constantly evolves
like an example of this would be the
pandemic that we are living in right now
the coronavirus
which isn't something that dialog models
that were trained prior to 2020 would
have been capable of talking about
uh we've seen and learned quite a bit
about how these models perform in
production through the alexa price so
i'm also quite
excited to see work on closing the
training loop with production and
enabling like you know parameter
efficient adaptation
thanks karthik uh will
yes lots of excitement about many areas
one of the areas that are the community
is you know
excited about and working on is the area
of understanding more compositional
input from the user
uh currently the majority of ai agents
just try to
detect the intent and and fill some
slots from the
user input but you know creating a full
semantic parse from the input of the
user is one of the areas that are you
know
becoming very interesting and very
challenging at the same time
another area that you know is becoming
also very
popular and and i'm excited about is the
area of using
in the contextual information beyond the
user input
you know what is happening in the news
what is on the screen while the speaker
is
talking uh you know the uh
previous interaction with the agent so
this is an area of
also uh interest and and research for
you know an area that my team is also
very excited about
interested in is people are building
those huge
uh models you know birth and vert large
and xx large and
and now gpt three and bigger models
so there emerged an area for you know
compressing distilling and compressing
and pouring these models into
much smaller sizes you know order of
magnitude smaller sizes that can be
practically served to you we see a lot
of publications in this area and a lot
of interest in this area very exciting
area and
very interesting as well uh one of the
uh challenges that people also face and
it's very popular
and research is to be able to learn from
very very
little amount of data similar to what
fabian described
in in his paper uh very challenging
because you know annotating data and
getting you know uh
supervised signal to training is not
an inexpensive process and sometimes
very expensive process so building
models that can learn from unlabeled
data that can learn across tasks
transfer between
tasks is a very popular area of research
uh
you know flu shot learning zero shot
learning this is a very interesting area
of research finally
we have been after accuracy for a long
period of time so the community now is
looking into
aspects other than accuracy so there is
a
very very important interest especially
for conversational ai agents
to keep the customer uh privacy
in mind you know building models that
are protective of the
user privacy and as well as provide the
bias free experience uh to our customers
the agent should
you know interact with the customer in a
bias-free fashion
and at the same time these models that
are built and these you know systems
that are built
are very protective of the customer uh
privacy
so these are a few headlines of what our
teams are interested in and the
community
is interested in
thanks to will whether those are all
exciting and i think whether those are
important
for both alexa or amazon as well as the
entire speech and nlp community
uh fabian can you share your thoughts
yeah i'm also very excited to actually
see
how much the field is evolving over the
past years so i'm
seeing that nlu is really breaking out
of these classical boundaries
of dialogue systems uh classical command
and control use cases
so showing much more naturalness more
interactions more
self-learning and and other cases that
is really great to see and especially as
mentioned by
by wayne and kartik all the deep
learning and large scale language
modeling applied to nlu
um they're from a product angle really
enabling us to build
many new experiences for customer
experiences
so we will have more natural more
appealing and much more
interactive devices on the market
in the future and this is really great
to see how how this field is evolving
and especially looking at this related
to a publication like pre-training and
distilling
such general purpose models or general
language models into
very specific problems domains or spaces
it's super great because it helps us to
reduce redials on
on data and we can really port the world
knowledge into our problem space and
benefit from from large scale
backhand models and from from the aspect
of multilingual modeling it's it's super
interesting for me personally to see
that one actually can combine multiple
languages in these models and there's
the possibility to leverage
cross-lingual synergies cross-lingual
learning and
this will help us a lot to to build our
systems in a more global
more language agnostic way without
thinking about i build a model now
for this language we really will be able
to to serve customers
in in multiple languages with a joint
effort because we can really learn
across these languages
because we will map like different
languages into the same space we will
learn
relations among them in this shared
space and it's very elegant and
efficient
so i'm personally very excited and
looking forward to see many more of
these publications around
multilingual and large scale modelling
that helps to to build real business
applications out of that
thanks fabian um i believe with
advancement from all of these areas
what our families has mentioned that
alexa is going to continue to give user
better the better
experience well with
that we are coming to the end of this
virtual discussion
and i want to thank my publisher for
sharing their
insights and their research and i want
to thank everyone for tuning into this
virtual event i encourage all of our
viewers to access the
publications during inter speech so you
can know more details
about the research from these panelists
and also other alexa scientists
these publications are also available on
our website
amazon.science where you can find
these publications as well as other
content about our
approach to customers the science
we would love to connect with you during
the conference or after the conference
so please feel free to drop by our
virtual booth
and you can schedule a meeting with any
of the alexa scientists
i will be happy to talk more about
alexa ai or amazon and with that
enjoying the rest of into speech
conference